ранговий мули баню буддійському монастирі
і шаршуд лінк на уралі вісь уже 20-го
клювання тут на горі качканар буддисти
чи знаєш spooky для своїх медитацій
між небом і землею
чому ті
і девін і за баром чоловіків залишок en el
ojo з витій для буду з теорій прахова
на темно залити нору до ласу та кусок
для мисцели стал і варнава промислів
асті
1 грудей стопарику але не вірні чиї роботи
струменеву твору
землі 5 статеві на мільярди в році і я
сумніваюся ще у колосі право
владністю на і михайла сальник у
вас побалую називають лама самий він
двадцять руки в томуза знову в той
монастир
дуже офісі націй профітної викликаної
теж для міс цілу влада посил і не
буду стив нелегальна
40 тисяч на містечко качканар живі по
суті лише і за рахунок
вірні що й промислів асти цьому
пріоритету влади краще ви дні
навіть батьки коли ми на батьки
колими школу закінчувала завжди казав і
ви добування з вашими будь не дай боже
всі наші гід і тут працювала
батут варіанті в мало обома сказала шат
і обмани посмішку дорогу і ти розбоєм
займатися більше нічого не завищується
сім'ю живо два типи 3 страв а сім'ю
годувати треба
без залізняку качканар наматамі вони
про будку вони робочих місць ту і ви дуб
результат на буддійські горі для місця в
металургії вже ви вирішено харчування ви
керуються повністю ми криємо мазь
від силомою матеріальним рича ми видані
жадібних претензій на моєму зовсім не яках
то чоловік моя предмету суп і решка вона
там просто прибувають на законно пробиваю
особа
незаконно бізнес і не буду позову
монастиря завищуються краще не ти ж не в
team messi ви буду і станемо aetna світу
завищувати ці світла для них злодії